we're good we're here welcome back thank
you how was the big stage you went to
New York yeah so what I did was I went
to New York and I originally went to
meet with some advertisers of ours and
to be wining and dining or what yeah
I'll tell you about it and then I went
to being the Gary Vaynerchuk podcast and
then I went to be on peasant pomp yeah
everyone knows him as pump pomp yeah and
I know his podcast it was cool did gary
vaynerchuk's podcast first thing in the
morning at 8:00 or 9:00 or 10:00 a.m.
when I got there I was a little groggy
from my flight because I took some
medicine when I flew it went okay we'll
see what happens
so you walk in what what happened yeah
so walked in so he has two offices in
New York one Hudson Yards which I've
been to before it's buzzin this one was
the studio it's a little quieter but
still pretty badass in Brooklyn Long
Island City Long Island City it is which
I don't know if that's Brooklyn or not
but it was awesome man and you guys know
each other you don't know each other so
is just like her social climate but we
had he knew who I was and obviously I
definitely know who he is and he knew
who our company was he he was totally
nice and he was really low-key at first
he wasn't like cocaine Gary yeah he was
like you guys do a little chitchat small
talk beforehand or you just got into me
so here's what happened we sat down and
there's like an audience there's like an
audience of like ten maybe five or ten
people me it was me and Adam on our side
of it he had an entourage and we sit
down and he goes all right go looks at
me and I was like I looked at add up I
would I go Gary I think you're
interviewing me he goes oh I am I was
like right Adam like is that right yeah
that's what we set up out of the safety
blanket
yeah Gary was like oh okay so tell me
about who you are like it was good it
was a nice guy that's good to know
yeah you know he's an easy target
because he's so loud yeah
I believe the screen went off there I
believe that he is totally legitimate
and a really good businessperson I think
his
company Vayner is really really hard to
run and he heard that he was currently
the CEO oh and CEO but great business
are being good business and he's totally
legitimate he's like because you can
like what makes you say that so long you
could put him in like the Donald Trump
category of a guy who talks a lot and
you're like I don't know this kind of
real deal right he's totally the real
deal he just talks a lot but what what
were the little tidbits that gave you
that impression right cuz I believe that
I'm not saying you're lying I asked him
I go so how do you like working here I
always ask employees I asked a front
desk I go what what's what you know and
you can kind of tell if they actually
like it yeah and when he has 800
employees so the and the office space
was it was really expensive real estate
there was really nice furniture
everything was set up professionally
it's a real business right so you could
tell what's legitimate and what is it
once you go in there in this Hudson
Yards office they had vaynermedia water
bottled water the office was buzzing
everyone had nice computers it wasn't
it's not a startup right felt like a
legit operation totally for two hundred
percent and kudos to him man he's
talented and you did the podcast you
know rate your performance I gave myself
a c-plus okay and then because I was it
was a I hadn't done any reps that day
like I did a pilot a podcast later that
day I had a Red Bull firing yeah all
right I'm on it it just it just fell a
little flat but Adam and his people said
it was one of their favorite ones
they've ever done and do you have a
little prep routine you would do if but
let's say before you get on stage before
you do an interview how do you you know
switch the light yeah well I typically
will like you know how it is like when
we're doing this thing I was in a piss I
was in a shitty mood a minute ago and
these lights turned on and you're like I
got a like snap out of it and what I do
is I talked to the receptionist or I'll
talk to the uber driver just to like
start it out of your hand get my words
going and getting a better happier mood
yeah and that's usually what I do okay
is that what you do no like
everything I try to like study and come
up with like a framework for how to do
it and like a technique and so I picked
up two things so I picked up one from
Conor McGregor that he I was watching
this documentary of hawk with a pen in
your mouth yeah so this I tried it and
it actually works fantastic so basically
you take a pencil or a pen you hold it
sort of horizontal sideways you bite on
it so it's in your mouth you know sort
of going out past your cheeks and then
you just talk for one minute and what
happens is because the pencils there in
your mouths in this awkward position
your tongue has to really work to like
flick over and under this thing to get
to the spots he usually goes to so you
end up enunciated way better I don't
know if it's placebo I don't know if it
really is like an actual warm-up for
your tongue but this [__] works I've
recorded myself before and after and I
can tell the difference and other I had
other people listen to it I said oh tell
me which one of these sounds better and
I don't know whether it's placebo or not
if that one works for me the other thing
is like a quick physical change so push
ups a wind sprint jumping jack a scream
music whatever I am a big believer that
that that the fastest way to change the
way you feel is through changing your
body rapidly with tan works that's like
a Tony Robbins ism Tony Robbins says
this great YouTube video if you go look
at if you're just YouTube young Tony
Robbins and it's you know the same guy -
25 years he's in a tank top and he's
given the speech and he talks about he
goes before I get on stage you know
people always ask me okay you're you're
public speaker you do you do a really
great job how do you do a great job of
this and he goes because I don't make
the mistakes most people do because most
people are sitting in a low energy shell
the body body posture sucks and then
they just get up on stage and they don't
warm up like an athlete would never do
that and he's like I treat myself like
an athlete I get myself in a mental
state a physical state he goes the
second thing I do I don't try to
memorize what I'm supposed to say
because when you try to memorize what
you say you're trying to prepare but
what ends up happening is your mind is
then editing it's comparing what you're
saying versus what you kind didn't
remember you're supposed to say is you
give this other whole thing going on in
your head that takes you away from the
moment third thing and this is the last
one he goes before I go up there
convinced myself that the audience has
to hear this like their lives depend on
this information like they need I'm here
to help and if I can get this across
like even with this podcast for example
it's like you know somebody is out there
they're commuting they're you know
they're they have this idea that they
haven't taken action on they're kind of
beating themselves up about it or you
know they look around at the five people
that they hang out with the most and
they're just like these people are not
like me and we're in their ear balls and
they're like oh there are people like me
out there and yes I should take some
action and yes I should have some
[__] energy today and so he's like I
just convinced myself that they have to
hear this and then I'm here to serve
them and I was like okay I do that just
thinking that has made me feel better
there you go another thing that I did
while I was out there is on Sunday night
I tweeted out so when I fly I take a lot
of xanax it's the only drug I do I don't
do any alcohol and sometimes the night
before I'll take it a little bit as well
because I really hate flying and so on
Sunday night I tweeted that I rented
this Airbnb which I did and I'm gonna
host a meet-up and I got 200 replies
saying let's meet up right and that I
couldn't do that so I only let 20 trend
subscribers come and so the trend
subscribers are also not 100 of you
listeners or not 100% of listeners are
subscribers but all subscribers are
listeners right and they so I met I
think that thirty ended up coming and it
was [__] awesome it was so cool up
this one kid flew up from South Carolina
or something and I treated this on the
meetup was Monday night I tweeted this
on Sunday night yeah like there was no
preparation like we all we did me and
Adam landed and on Monday morning we
went to the Mexican place next door and
said hey can you bring over enough tacos
for 20 people there's two or three
hundred bucks and go buy some beer and
we'll pay you more money and that's all
we did and it was awesome
yeah these people are [__] fanatical
is crazy
it's nuts it's really odd who was the
most interesting person so many
interesting people one guy
there was this one guy I I forget his
name maybe he's listening he was an
older the eldest guy there which is not
old but minutes fifty s or 40s and he
built was it builds custom electric
cards cars and through the trends groups
sold 50 cars just another custom
electric car I mean like he was making
uh like they took a they take a Prius or
it took no they took yeah they took like
a some type of pickup truck and made it
an electric delivery van oh wow for a
cannabis company in LA cuz um who else
did I mean I mean I met all types of
people one guy who sells fake boobs for
a living so he sells his he'll be more
fairchild he does ever talk to on
twitter hunter yeah yeah I see this guy
on my Twitter all the time yeah he sells
fake boobs yeah his boss invented like a
better dude what's in his bio cuz I've
looked at this guy's bio and he's not
advertising this so let's see what this
girl a DD we're just sitting down a
hunter came and we were just shooting
the [__] what do you do and this woman a
DD she's nice I've met her before we
were just sitting there and she's like
well I sell breast implants and we were
like what and we just start talking I
was like so do you have like a woman who
comes with you and like shows you like
shows the buyers like you need like
sales brochures like how do you have
like how do you show that your boobs are
the best and he was just like walking
through this whole process it was crazy
I had never heard of such a thing yeah
me neither but of course he came up from
Virginia for this that's great all right
cool so you can do more of that of what
well you and I need to do more so what
we can do is New York that we could get
I easily we could have gotten 200 people
yeah so we can do one in New York I
think a cast or whatever we use tells us
where people are right we got to go to
Canada we got to go to Utah when we
shout it out Utah I know I still get
more do the number of these friendly ass
Utah you know citizens whatever they're
called you times reach out all the time
like hey when you guys are here I got
you so maybe like it feels good to be
taken care of like that does feels great
made hospitality hmm February yeah when
you end of February we should do a thing
where
could try to hit up like three cities in
five days right
maybe maybe so I got into this thing I
don't have I told you about this this
thing called reality have you heard of
this No
so basically you know Jewish people have
birthright yeah and I don't know exactly
how many the mechanics of birthright
work but from what I understand all
about it if you're Jewish you get to go
it's paid by the sort of wealthy Jewish
people around for all the Christians
fundamental Christians Christians who
believe that Israel's the land for Jews
Wow okay didn't know that so basically
that's a cool thing for Jewish people
you're shaking your head are you Jewish
Henry but you know about it
you just stunned yeah I've never been
more jealous than where my friends go on
birth right and then come back it's like
this mini study abroad
yes great and so then I was like all
right what is this you know how do I get
more of this so they have this program
called reality reality 20/20 if you want
to look it up and it's basically you
could be in these different groups you
can be in entertainment it could be in
technology you can be in whatever social
impact you apply to get in if you get in
I apply I've applied before I got
rejected a few years ago this time I
applied I got in and it's like a small
group I don't know 30 people 40 people
that get accepted and get to go it's not
all expenses paid but it's like most
expenses paid and so yeah anyways I'm
going on this trip late May now and
we're gonna see what this is all about
to Israel and I don't think it you don't
have to be Jewish this one's not like
it's like it's more like you know
Israel's right you know sort of gotta
start up and kind of thought leadership
and young people that sort of thing the
future leaders I mean it's like a not in
a bad way it's a propaganda thing it's
like it's like a program yeah so I'm
doing that but my question to you when
you going it's late may
so first scared of Quran of iris may not
go I was going to Germany in May so we
should talk about Crone advisor in a
second but secondly why did you have all
the good things why don't other people
do this this seems like a great
birthright seems great Jews and Mormons
yeah Mormon so there's like the same
thing but Mormons might be better now
because they don't drink do Mormons have
these perks like that like birthright or
something yeah they have all types of
[__] dude and they're all real good at
basketball and juice
they're all like real similar well the
thing I like is the sort of pay it
forward thing I think Silicon Valley has
this a lot where a lot of people who
move here they hesitate to reach out to
people because they're like well why
would this person one help me I you know
I have nothing to offer but like that is
the culture of Silicon Valley is to pay
it forward it is to help the like next
person who doesn't know anything and I
feel like Jews have this in their
culture and I feel like Mormons have
this in their culture you know I'm
Indian I don't feel like there's this
same it's not as strong for Indian
people to sort of try to help out the
next and I think part of its cos are
such a big population you can't afford
to do it there's like I don't know six
million Jewish people on earth or
something crazy and they run the world
so I think you know with a small number
of people you can offer this like much
more high-touch help each other model I
agree
let me make one quick announcement
before we get into it and I won I wanted
to make this on the top of this maybe
maybe my chop it up maybe our editor can
chop it up but what I want to do is I've
heard about these people say subscribe
unsubscribe subscribe again alright and
I want to test it so last time we asked
our viewers for more reviews and we now
have 550 maybe we got 500 400 reviews
and in just a couple of days you guys
are really active and they all sent me
messages I try to reply to everyone to
do I did now yeah I went okay so here's
haven't got a reply I thought you did
get reply so here's what I want people
to do and the reason I'm gonna I want to
do this is because I think people like
seeing us succeed and they like seeing
the journey yeah so you're gonna help us
succeed so here's what you do if you
have an iPhone you're gonna go to like
the the menu where you can like turn
your Wi-Fi and Bluetooth off and all
that there's a button on the bottom
right where you hit record okay record
that that's gonna record your screen
then go to the podcast app go to my
first million click subscribe and then
unsubscribe and then subscribe again
send us a video of that happening and if
you do also send us a question that you
want and we'll answer your question yeah
bake a Q&A and this will tell us the
truth right because there's like we need
to run the experiment need to know is
this how is it does this actually work
or is this just like a myth
and if you send us your question ideally
send it via Twitter yeah so everyone
could see and can comment in that way
it's easy
so just record yourself subscribing and
subscribing and then research gravity do
it a bunch of times record yourself post
that on Twitter tag one of us or both of
us and then on that same thread ask your
question and if you don't have a
question that's fine too and then we're
gonna look at the chart so we're gonna
see what this does to the chart movement
I think it's gonna actually boost the
chart movement if I if the theory is
correct you know I believe this is why
podcaster to ask people to do this is
because this should actually work and if
it does here's what we'll do if this
does work and people keep doing this
what we'll do is with only the people
who do that well like take a screenshot
of our analytics and set it to them yeah
yeah well share the data
yeah no problem okay you want to get
into some stuff about coronavirus or you
want to yeah okay so I'm terrified of
coronavirus and you know generically I'm
terrified you know I was terrified
without information and then I started
looking into a little bit more so they
don't even know about it can you explain
what the yeah so basically there's a
couple of these viruses they're
influenza strains and so the flu flu
yeah so basically a few years ago you
probably heard you know SARS or swine
flu and so you know the very first time
I think SARS happened there was you know
kid got this flu goes to the doctor's
office they're like okay this is the flu
and kid dies within like a very short
amount of time they're like well that
was odd that doesn't usually happen so
they took a sample and sent it to like
the CDC or whoever right like they sent
it to some lab to say you know what do
you see here there was this was a very
unusual case the health deteriorated so
quick that's not typical to the flu and
what they realized was hey this is a new
strain called I think it was like h1 and
five at the time and it was like this is
only ever found in animals this is the
first time it's crossed over from animal
to human and so that was bird flu when
that happened and then so there's been
these different sort of very very deadly
viruses SARS which art which was very
very popular MERS which happened in the
Middle East respiratory syndrome and so
it's kind of what these Middle East
respiratory I think syndrome is the what
MERS stands for and SARS is sort of the
same thing and so the thing with these
was that you know although there's a lot
of hoopla around
SARS and bird flu like SARS killed less
than a thousand people less than a
thousand total fatalities not a big drop
in the bucket as far as the death bucket
goes on earth coronavirus already killed
like three thousand plus people so
already much bigger than that
the reason it's scary though is actually
and for a while people were like oh
don't worry the fatality rate is low
fatality rates like I don't know three
percent for this whereas four stars it
was like super high I don't know I don't
think that number is like majority of
people who have it died where's where
this three percent means you get it but
you have a good chance of living but the
big problem with that and the article
that I read was called why you're
probably why we probably can't contain
coronavirus why you probably are gonna
end up getting coronavirus is because
this virus is extremely contagious but
has these symptoms that are very
problematic so it takes a while for your
symptoms to show up so you have it and
you carry it for like you know 14 days
without showing symptoms so you'll be
spreading this around and not even
realizing you have it then once you have
it you don't just like deteriorate and
like your health doesn't go to [__]
where they you know you're in the
hospital they quarantine you it's like
you know it starts innocent and it gets
worse over time
so the infectious period is so much
longer that there's basically no way to
quarantine this thing there is no way
for us to contain this and so what the
article was saying was like ironically
because it is not as fatal and it's not
as bad for you right away this thing is
gonna be unstoppable most likely case
second thing with that was I guess
there's four like and you know typical
strains of the flu which is why you can
get your flu shot and still catch the
flu every year so you guys are these
four different strains and the vaccine
doesn't cover or sort of all all the
different variations and and so this
guy's case was that most likely this is
now just a fifth annual you know strain
that we're gonna have to live with and
it's just gonna suck it's a very very
you know kind of a downer also I'm sure
you know sort of the bio nerds out there
gonna be like you know there's 15
million strains that's right but like
that's the summary that I took away and
if you want to just get the point that's
the point and so what you have up here
is d2c stuff so like my I looked at my
portfolio
today is like [__] so lost money
yesterday off the stock market so crazy
shit's happening all around so
generically stock market you know people
get paranoid bonds you know people flee
to bond stock goes down that sort of
thing other funny stuff happening you
know zoom the conferencing software so
the stock ticker zoom goes up 50 percent
today because [__] but wait there's more
it's the stock ticker zero om but that's
not zooms actual handle zooms actual
handle is ZM so people are buying the
wrong stock because they think people
are gonna be working from home and
teleconferencing in and so they're
buying zoom which does something else
altogether so much small cam stock I
don't know Henry check what the stock 4
zom actually does and it just tiny
stocks I would jump 50 percent today and
like you know but you could actually
predict this because this happened also
at the IPO whoever bought zoom the other
thing got his huge pop at zooms IPO
because of this so we could have
predicted this one I love when that
happened but all kinds of [__] up
things some other things smart friends
are basically saying hey if you need
percents my smart friends you know
people who actually read the real
information and like understand how the
world works they were like hey if you
need prescription drugs you should start
stockpiling because most of its coming
from China and the supply chain globally
is [__] and like the world doesn't
have that like friend friend of a friend
basically how the [__] do stockpile
prescription meds basically buy up buyer
refills and and so the there's no global
plan B for what happens if China gets
sick or slowed down we don't have
another like supply chain and so all
kinds of things are suffering and I have
friends that have D to see companies
that buy their [__] they're back gonna
and they're saying [__] yeah months and
months backed up I was talking to a
supplier yesterday and he was like even
if we come back to work there's you know
all the other factories that we depend
on the printing factory the packaging
guys and they're not coming like the
workers are just not coming back because
in most factories in China the workers
don't actually live in that city
permanently so for Chinese New Year
which is when this happened so Chinese
New Year's a month long holiday yeah
well we have a all Chinese intern he
told us all about it he goes he goes
it's the largest
day in the world right because every
Chinese person everybody goes home and
when they go home they go back to very
rural areas and already there's this
problem where they don't cut me and
often that will come back as you know
they don't want to be living in some
other city working in a factory but with
this people are just not coming back and
so there's no replacements it's like a
very dire situation well and like
obviously the human level also
incredibly dire situation so to turn
[__] into gold where is the opportunity
here I mean what's gonna happen do you
think that this is gonna impact have
long-term impact with China China making
[__] and you have to go elsewhere
I don't know so there's a question of
like so two two theories one is for
stuff like this the people who are gonna
do really well they didn't start now
they started something two years ago a
blog on being a prepper or whatever and
today's your day you know like this is
your month and so I don't think the I
don't know how much I am interested in
sort of like today opportunity also
feels kind of [__] up we talked about
Judy the other day right the Judy sort
of survival bags my friend Joe speiser
bought something from like survivor kit
calm and he got an email from them
saying we have a hundred times our
normal volume we apologized but we're
gonna make it happen right so those the
Judy thing that which the respiratory of
demands those are not on the Judy bag
but the respiratory masks are just like
out of stock you can't get them and
that's like the thing you need is like
to protect your no they're not long gone
no one can pounce on that yeah we
covered this guy who launched a company
called um Judy yeah Judy it's a
emergency kit yep an orange like
emergency backpack ready big my wife
texted me today and said what's gonna
buy a bunch of stuff I feel the same way
more people are doing this have you ever
been an emergency situation by the way
have you ever like been in a city when
like a flood happens or anything like
that it's really bizarre how it feels no
I was in Hawaii our honeymoon there was
a hurricane in Hawaii
oh I wake up any minute when I was there
and so we went to the grocery store
where I know first we go to the hotel
and they're like hey um we have early
checking available we're like well
that's cool thanks cuz we're a honeymoon
and they're like no we just have like a
lotto
in rooms there I was like what's going
on they're like well have you seen the
weather report like there's our
hurricane this week of course I don't
take the weather so I booked my
honeymoon on a hurricane week and so we
go to the grocery store and it's like
the zombie attack has happened like all
the water bottles are gone like the
shelves are empty people are just
checking out like four carts worth it's
really like it's an odd eerie eerie
feeling when that happens yeah this
thing my issue here's an opportunity if
someone wants to go for is you know how
cool is it there's a political check is
that what's called political political
fact
you mean like the fact-checking thing
yeah I don't know so what you do is like
did Bloomberg really say this right and
it goes that's what I want for a
coronavirus right now I don't know what
true and what is it so there's a blog
called
I believe it's called the prepared calm
it is exactly what you want it is plain
English it's like here's the facts not
the overreaction and by the way we'll
tell you about the overreaction and why
it's an overreaction but here's the
facts what's presented in a calm calm
way but site is beautiful it works great
on your phone I tweeted at the guy who
started like this is a like thank you
for making this yeah I was like thank
you for making this site because this is
exactly what I need in this situation I
feel like it's like it's cool I'm into
this so scary situation yeah scary
all-around best of luck to everybody
yes for sure okay you want to move on
yeah let's move on okay oh I have a few
interesting things that happened as cool
companies that we could talk about the
first thing is something that has made a
huge impact on me and I think more
people need to take advantage of it
which is transparent numbers so
basically there's a group of people out
there who believe that transparency is
good and they share all of their revenue
they chair they share their every metric
about their business as deep as
everyone's salary their bank balance
churn how much it cost to acquire
customer how much a customer stays on
for everything some are a little bit
less will they'll share how many
customers they have how much revenue
they have what the bank balances more
people should follow these businesses I
for one and totally against that I don't
think you should ever reveal that but
I'm happy they do and yeah so some
examples so thoroughly so first of all
my friend encore what's encores last
name he runs teachable I don't remember
his last name if you google on it can
you tell me on course last name founder
of teachable okay so he reveals on
Twitter the valuation of every round
what is it Matt Paul yes net said knock
Paul knock Paul he reveals the valuation
of every right every time they just
raise like 20 million bucks yeah duh
whatever hundred something really good
and he reveals how much revenue they
have how many customers they have it's
awesome yes I love that the other guy is
Sahil Sahil from Gumroad shitty business
seems like an awesome guy he reveals
every single month yeah although you
could Google Gumroad founder Sahil it's
on his Twitter if you just he doesn't
have a tweet lane sitting after you
don't even have to dive into the books
so yeah here's some forty characters um
Joel from buffer he does this they
actually just switch so if you go to
bear metrics calm or google bear metrics
they have like 18 different companies
that do this and it's pretty cool and
Joel from buffer used to be on there
there are 22 million dollar your company
so pretty valuable and they were well
they feel everything every employee
salaries like name salary equity you
know level everything and you know what
they're changing they're showing less
and less because have you talked to him
do you know why it becomes problematic
when you add more people yeah duh so I
get you know guy you know creates you
know turns his kitchen into a man cave
instead gets a girlfriend and he's like
oh she doesn't like it it's like yeah oh
[__] man like I told you this like when
you bought the plasma and put it on the
fridge people don't like their salary
being public people get upset when they
see their co-worker who slacks off and
works from home two days a week and they
say because people understand
like different people have different
situations it's not like so so they did
it I think at a smart way which is they
basically were like they use it as
customer acquisition yeah it's part of
their story because they got their ass
kicked by HubSpot and so they like you
know this has become a bit of a playbook
for small business of business SAS
companies which is look you know
acquisition of customers is hard if my
customer is a small business owner what
a small business what would bring a
small business owner to me what content
could I put out there that would make a
small business owner come so instead of
saying seven tips to have more effective
meetings they were like here's our
here's our P&L for this month and sure
enough a lot of people wanted to see
that so a lot of people discovered their
product through this and so you know
maybe this lines up totally with their
values and that's why they did it but
death
definitely it was a great way for people
to discover their business I didn't use
buffer but I read all their [__] and if
anybody ever needed a solution like
buffer I was like Oh buffer you should
use buffer why because otherwise I
wouldn't have even known about them and
so this was a pretty counterintuitive
thing that they did and they were the
only ones doing it and so you always get
paid when you're the only one doing it
if it's juicy yeah and so one more
person who's doing it and his business
is way better than buffer I love this
guy's business so it's my friend Nathan
Barry I've met Nathan a while ago and
Nathan has this company called
convertkit they do close to 2 million
monthly recurring revenue so 24 million
he owns 100% of it it's right it's
probably a hundred to two hundred
million dollar company like it's really
valuable because once customers are
locked in it's basically a MailChimp
competitor it's an email that seems high
to two million a month you said oh
that's for sure how much they do so they
do to me know that part so 24 million a
year so 24 million you think they're
worth what 10 times 10 times that okay
maybe growing like a weed maybe people
don't switch from their email platform
yeah it all depend on the retention so
can you pull up actually can you open it
open up their their metrics so just as
hi just Google like I bear metrics
dashboard or something I forgot what the
URL is but it's like something dot bear
metrics comm and it's like their whole
companies like here's how many new
customers we got here's how many people
turned this month it's like all their
graphs
and you can use it for your company he
even showed how much profit they make I
think it's like vert kit it's like yeah
here it is
you gotta zoom in there you go so this I
don't know if this is their business so
this is like the example thing but it's
like monthly recurring revenue net
revenue fees this is somebody else do
convertkit
yeah do convertkit bear metrics I've
been convertkit revenue maybe I also use
convertkit I actually I pay for
subscription because I'm like this
product is so [__] powerful I don't
actually have many sequences set up I
have a sequence of one email right now
which is not a sequence it's just an
email
but I think it's a great product I love
convertkit
I love Nathan Nathan's a great guy
Nathan's only twenty six or seven years
old we talked to so we talked about the
idea of doing a drip sequence to build a
newsletter for women going through
pregnancy and like week by week and I
had a friend I are starting a random
listener reach out on Twitter is like
I'm doing this here's my kind of unique
asset I have to go about this and how
should I set this up and I sent him to
convertkit I was like dude your problem
is gonna be solved in like you know the
next 90 minutes what are people leaving
barometric so why can't you find it here
you go
1.7 million oh is that it what's the URL
yeah so 1.7 million monthly recurring
revenue and you could just look at the
return so annual run rate doing 20
million a year which is up 1.7 percent
that's got to be how much this month
revenue cheering 5.1 percent per month
it's not great either well it's because
it's a small to medium business like if
you're turning 5% a month that's like
what's isn't what's the net growth so 5%
a month is the churn what's the new
business every month one and a half 1/2
percent
yeah so he's negative then per month no
I think that that churn growth month
that growth number takes into account
churned actually okay gotcha okay that's
the but this is because it's the the
average revenue even says so they make
on average $60 is a $60 a month per user
right and on the right of media
business gonna have a it's gonna have
higher turn compared to other SAS but if
you're a real sicko you could just look
at the livestream on the right and see
every minute when somebody pays them
it'll say like right now it says 20
million dollars paid by you know
anonymous company dude he's got a lot of
failed payments here and get on that
Nathan what's going on you can't be
failing is 3 out of the 12 payments here
failed for he has a chart that says
which ones fail so these these companies
are badass
so you wouldn't do it no I think what
about a part of what you do the email
list size the revenue I don't want to
share anything publicly I'll say like 8
figures or write something no I just
don't think it brings a lot of good
either you know when a company's trying
to raise or sell their business because
like two months before all these
articles will come out just like handing
over they're handing over information
why is that happening because they want
to raise the ground they want to sell
their company in the next six months I
don't know I'm not a fan of it at one
time when I when I did my first
conference when I was younger it made
like 60 grand in profit and I told
everyone in the blog post and I hated
the attention so I'm never gonna do it
again okay so let's talk about pipe comm
you know pipe comm I saw this and I was
like dude this is awesome I was I came
to the I came to a little scratch pad to
write it down and you already had it
written down okay so here's what here's
here's let me set the stage here so when
you have a subscription business I'm
talking about software subscription but
maybe it could work for all types of
stuff what happens is you do one of two
things the first is you say all right
you sign this deal and you owe us $200 a
month and so that is a $2,400 a year
subscription service and the company
that is your customer will pay you $200
a month what a lot of companies prefer
to do but this is actually a lot harder
as they say alright you signed one-year
contract let's get all of your payment
upfront right now the here's the balance
here is do you want or this is what
people think they can either get more
customers and allow them to pay monthly
right or they can get less customers but
allow them to pay annually and get all
that cash flow upfront and what what's
it called pipe what they do
pipe comm if you have a businesslike
convertkit and they have a history of
three years and it says look every month
our churn rate historically is five
percent pipe can go okay so you have all
these customers paying you each month
let's just I don't know how they
discount it but they probably probably
discount it a lot so they D rate risk it
and this'll say well let's just assume
that you're gonna have a twenty percent
monthly churn right we're just gonna
we'll give you all that money up front
and you owe us as the money comes in
with a little bit of interest right
awesome awesome business so I've so many
thoughts all right so a couple things
first the financial infrastructure
what's what's really going on here the
financial infrastructure for software
companies and tech businesses is being
rebuilt so we already had investors
right angel investors seed investors
series-a investors blah blah blah but
then you have a bank for startups
Mercury started by you know some
successful founders from Hayes app they
started Mercury it's supposed to be a
bank designed for startups and then you
have things like bricks or ramp which we
talked about which is like business
credit card designed for startups
because the legacy institutions don't
understand how to value these companies
how to assess risk or how to like fund
and finance these companies then you
have things that are you know like
market places where you can buy and sell
to buy and sell online businesses like
quiet-like brokerage or wherever you
have due diligence firms that pop up
that specialize in software business
like centrica then you have you know
guys like pipe which basically say great
you know you have a cash flow problem
but you have steady we know you have a
predictable book of business we will
give you the cash upfront and we'll take
a Vig off the top of that and so I think
these are all really smart businesses
each one at a different part of the
financial stack yes we software
technology Capacete we use it's it's
pipe but for media and publishers and
pipe has raised seventy million in
funding they're kind of stupid because
we use them and we have a million
millions of dollars in credit from them
and we won't leave them because it's a
wonderful service but the reason why
they're kind of stupid is because the
markets a lot smaller
right then software and the numbers are
a lot smaller right I think pipe will be
a multi-billion dollar company yeah or
the one problem or that this is a lot of
there's a lot of competition yeah I
think the aggregate will be so
for example this is also happening on
the customer side right so companies
like a firm or sessile or after pay
consumers yeah that's on the consumer
side but same same idea which is like
they're trying to provide different
financial instrument that like the
traditional financial company like this
the current sort of incumbents aren't
really figuring out how do we help
ecommerce companies sort of how do we
help merchants you know turn their
products into monthly payments for their
customers but a firm came out and did it
and you know fast bit our sorry not fast
Bay after pay I think after Paisley's
dollar company or something like that in
Australia a firm is a multi-billion
dollar company here doing the exact same
thing and they're all fighting over
these merchants I love this [__] man I
say [__] the big banks I [__] hate
them yeah I hate him so much I hate
having to talk to our rep they don't
understand me right they don't
understand so we're doing so Sean are
the producer and editor for the podcast
he had an idea so I asked him one day
because I you know I haven't want to
sort of my right-hand man so sometimes I
just ping him with just random questions
I said what's the biggest idea in your
head right now I was like you know
what's the biggest startup idea you got
and you know he's 20 21 years old I
don't know exactly how old he is busy
young guy and so he goes well I've been
a you know freelancer contractor for you
and many other people for last few years
and he's like why doesn't an a sort of
fast pay or pipe exists for contractors
like I have my invoice just give me the
money now and then you wait to like when
the company pays you take it and you
take 5% so figure I did half the thing
and I've actually heard this idea a few
times before of like you know my wife
was a you know a consultant you know and
so she always got paid like this on a 30
or 60 day cycle and she would have you
know 20 grand sitting and outstanding
payments if she could just get the 20
grand you know headache free she would
take nineteen fifty you know she would
take 19 thousand out of that just to get
the money now and not have to keep
following up via email to be like hey
have you paid it yet and like all that
stuff and so the problem seems real and
this is more of a question to the
audience of like what am I wrong about
what don't I get about this idea seems
like a great idea on the surface what's
the problem with this idea because I've
heard it bandied around a few times over
the years it's not a
it's not a like super niche idea I think
a lot of people could have this idea so
what's wrong with it and I think that
you can learn just as much from common
ideas that don't work as you can from
great ideas that do work if you start to
identify why does this seemingly good
idea not work why have people tried and
failed over and over again there's a lot
to learn as an entrepreneur yeah I'm
taking that I so pipe coms out I'm
loving those things all right yeah one
thing hey Henry there's a guest
downstairs would you mind letting her in
and she's gonna join us for like the
next segment yeah
Julia what's up hi how are you doing
well thanks for having me you're already
my good books cuz you actually listen to
the podcast not all the guests do I do
my homework yes yes I I have a there's a
bunch of employee fans great they found
out and it was I mean like they'd been
really gunning for me to have a chance
shout out to them you have like that
like corny name for your employees like
yeah brilliant so that is literally a oh
my god changed it yeah well but then
everyone's like hey did you just like
come up with that cuz that is not that
great and so I think like you know
someone better with words was like how
about just Everly's yeah you're fired
actually I could say something like that
you know with bebo somebody tried to
like do that and I was like thank god
there's not a nice one because I don't
want this Erica thing
yeah Bieber's that minute by the way I'm
followed by Justin Bieber on Twitter no
big deal yeah
so cross ten thousand followers and
Justin Bieber follows me I do pretty
without reply how many it's got to be
one of those BOTS that's just funny zoo
thing follow I don't know Henry
Justin Bieber a number of followers will
find out the only way this goes down for
me it's not one of the top 300 thousand
friends of Justin Bieber that's better
than I would have thought I thought the
number was gonna be like 10 million
so for once okay so it's beginning so
you have sell your Juliet I really well
is your company name but your name's
Julia cheek yes
cool man thank you I hate my last name
and so I'm always thinking like you know
just totally rebranding it to something
cool but then I know people will be like
did you just change your last name to
try to sound cool which is probably the
least cool thing right I kind of got the
opportunity to do that because I decided
I had a choice to do Julia Taylor which
was my maiden name or if I wanted to and
I got married take on cheek yeah and it
was just sort of unique because I did it
you did it
uh-huh okay great and so for people
listening who are like okay great who is
this person why are they joining the
show
give us the like 30 seconds about what's
interesting about you yeah so I'm really
a cheek I'm the founder and CEO of
Everly well we are based in Austin we
are about to celebrate our five year
anniversary which is hard to believe but
probably the most interesting thing
about me starting this company is I
started a company in the blood testing
space in the direct-to-consumer space
coming with no entrepreneurial
background or healthcare background
whatsoever and had every kind of X in
the box of Y you would write write I was
a management consultant and I went at
Deloitte went got my MBA had a really
traditional Harvard had a really
traditional corporate all about the
pedigrees yeah I hate it I don't care if
Sam's like Harvard okay I'm in yeah yeah
there's definitely some interesting ties
I think that turned me on to being an
entrepreneur when I was there but
certainly like i was really in the
corporate path and then had this idea
when I was working at MoneyGram and left
my job to do it and I can confidently
say a hundred percent of people who know
me was like this is definitely gonna
fail there's no way it's gonna work so
what's the call yeah so when I was five
years ago when I was working at
MoneyGram I had a bunch of all these
unexplained health symptoms this is
super common which you hear for Herman
and their late 20s and their 30s as they
have chronic fatigue aches and pains
they're not taken seriously at doctors
and so I went to five or six different
doctors on good health insurance and
each of them are in different blood
tests I never got my results I paid over
twenty five hundred dollars out of
pocket
thing material showed up or was
communicated to me but he never got
results on you I personally didn't
receive my person was the doctor or even
if they called me like I missed the call
nobody ever caught they said we'll call
you if anything is abnormal well like
what does that mean you tested a hundred
different things like just because
something's not totally out of whack
doesn't mean there's not interesting or
useful information there so I sat down
and I looked at the health insurance
landscape and I thought man people are
gonna have to start paying for all this
in a more meaningful way than we are
today
and I'm at least confident that my
cohort of women between like 25 and 45
can't get the testing that they need
right and I think I can solve that and
to really start it out honestly not that
it wasn't a big vision but it was a
little bit like if you if you think
about the first group you're solving a
problem for that's what we launched for
so today we have 35 different tests on
every liberal comm on Amazon target CBS
Kroger we work with Humana and we offer
consumer initiated testing for
everything from STI testing heart health
food sensitivity etc it's like 90
percent of common test coverage from
what you would get from the doctor I've
raised over 50 million dollars from 5-0
from Western East Coast feces that was
after obviously having like three rounds
of clawing my way through funding and
then suddenly things did get easier and
we actually grew from zero to see we did
40 million in sales last year
yeah our third year in operation okay no
coronavirus no coronavirus ya know where
the for specially for the for the
healthcare entrepreneur and we have to
do i have to learn not to do that yeah
you know if we did I think we I wouldn't
be here right now do something else but
um but I'm hopeful there's progress as
we learned today from Gilead and a
couple other companies I'm hopeful
someone's closed on it unfortunately no
it's I mean it's a combination of new
customer acquisition and repeat we have
a really healthy repeat business because
a lot of our tests are things like
cholesterol it's not recurring we do
have enterprise contracts that are
recurring for Medicare but it's a mix
what I would call one time repeat and
then actual recurring contracts which is
there's challenges there's good and bad
I think when you have a one time heavy
business up front you have to build a
good set of unit economics from the
get-go so that you're not just
optimizing on this like promise of
payback right right so that's been good
for us on the other hand we've had to be
super super disciplined in a way that I
think some consumer brands haven't been
right so you're based out of Austin yeah
this do you see at home yes test that
then gets sent to a lab a partner lab
they analyze it you get the full report
it's like here's everything here's
what's interesting about this you could
share it it's like the way that it
should be like if you didn't even you
didn't have to like invent this if you
just ask the layperson you're like how
should this work okay that's the
description and then you just made that
like happen in real life the other thing
that's interesting is you were on Shark
Tank
I was so as a fan of reality TV man Sam
both watched the challenge probably the
trashiest reality show yeah we did it
all come out already and they just
released it today episode three of that
one good show have you seen it I don't
think yet do you know the premise I do
know the premise they put people in
rooms and they don't I'm gonna have to
get married shut up the show language
now you're gonna get like eliminated
survivor style do you just edit you out
like a you just not sure never again if
you didn't propose insolence of
happening is it's ten days behind a wall
you talk to this person and you're
speed-dating basically behind a wall
kind of like deciding who you like yeah
and then someone proposes through the
wall so they're like can you come close
to the wall please I'm out of me now and
I want to you know I see you marry me
and then but the thing is that I thought
that's where the show would end but then
they like put them in the real world
together and they're like all right
you're gonna get married in 30 days and
see what happens good job in flakes yes
tell me about how it came about you you
apply many times one time how'd you go
on yeah so shark tank was an ink
honestly I am a huge fan of the show I
also a huge fan of my own experience and
that's not I think what everyone has to
say but I always tell people I think it
can be a really game-changing thing for
entrepreneurs if you do it the right way
it is a lot of frickin work a ton of
work so I once you're on or before your
before you're on ok um so I would say
like so I we aired in November of 2017
good no this is like a nine-month
process of I would say the year of 2017
80% of my year was so we applied its and
by we me and it's like a 50 page written
application online oh no it is printed
and written out I tried to like use a
PDF Editor I mean it was like yeah like
it was like a decade ago right the thing
I write this whole thing out I will be
honest I was I was a finalist at
TechCrunch battlefield internal 16 the
producers scout from three companies
so they reached out so it's kind of like
if you're thinking about American Idol
maybe which I would never be but you you
either can get contacted and sort of put
in the front and to audition or you kind
of blend in or wait line so it's not
that I had necessarily a better chance
but I did get shortcut into the
application process so filled that out
the obligation probably takes 40 hours
and then you have to sign all their
contracts and basically sign your
identity and image away to ABC for in
perpetuity but um and then from there
you do a voice interview with producers
you do a video interview as well with
the application then another video
interview of your pitch and then from
there the producers work with you for
about four months on like what is your
story what is your brand what is your
script and then ultimately your what I
think people don't realize on sharing a
story it's a human interest story you
are there to make good reality TV but it
is your decision the producers will help
you and advise you but this is your gig
and it's up to you to decide how you
want to display yourself and who you
want to be on TV but they can then
decide whether or not to air you do you
still remember opening because you
probably drilled it like I did I did and
I will tell you I thought I was like
really good and comfortable at public
speaking and then I did
sounds like okay I was really bad and
now now I feel comfortable yeah I did so
I signed or I shook on the largest deal
ever for a female entrepreneur in terms
of valuation so yet with Lori Grenier
she is on board she's been tremendous
because of QVC or when for me it was
really at the time we had no
brick-and-mortar retail presence and I
knew that that was a priority for us to
create a product it was like actually
accessible and ubiquitous and that's
actually in hindsight been a really good
move for us but I felt that she would be
invaluable in helping us to get all of
those stores yeah she really helped with
packaging and branding and making
something that's accessible when you're
trying to like sell a testing kit where
either people think it's a DNA kit right
where they have no idea what it is being
able to differentiate out me of like 10
seconds to grab so so the deal we shook
on was a lot because there's the shake
there's the actual deal oh yeah I can't
disclose that Oh however we're different
yes it was better for the company
and probably better for Lori and better
because honestly why does the deal
change so normally there's like they do
diligence and they might change it right
for their favor you're saying it better
for you guys it went that route so there
was a and it's very case-by-case so what
happens after the show is make sure your
project because your audio yours what
you're saying is great I want to make
sure we're getting it all set my audio
paranoia right here make sure your talk
louder than you're comfortable talking
so after you shake on the deal on the
show a fair number of those deals I
think it's something like over half
never come to fruition at all and then
another quarter or so actually change
and then another quarter get done at the
terms that you shook on yeah I think it
really eat shark eat shark has a
different approach
so like I they're totally you then go
into their management company right so
you're going into Mark Cuban companies
or Lori or Neer's companies and so it's
not a I don't know what eat sharks
processes I can say Lori's was super
fair they go through very detailed
diligence on everything but but you know
what the show actually does diligence on
you
they have adventure analyst
on board so they run diligence on you
before you ever pitch I pitched I my
valuation was 20 million post-money so
that was a it was a line of credit deal
at an 8% interest rate for five percent
of the company and was it like hey deal
offer on the spot or do you have this
like long pause where you like can I
think and write this down well in my
case every shark was out and I actually
knew I wanted either lawyer or mark
green sorry Lori or Mark Cuban and so I
was really excited about it and so I
really did want to work with her and it
was a good deal so I actually sat on the
show because you're supposed to
negotiate I said because it makes a good
TV
yes and so I said I know I'm supposed to
negotiate but I want to take this deal
so I didn't you do have it is really
what you see like you can exit you can
talk about it with your partner you can
call a lifeline or a friend they may
edit that out or whatever else but you
can take a minute to think about it
what's something people don't don't see
or don't realize that is different from
having actually gone through it versus
watching what's one I think people know
it's edited I don't think people realize
how long the actual time filming can be
from when you walk in and walk out to
like what they edit down to five minutes
so it varies but mine was probably an
hour and they added it to seven minutes
some people's have gone on up to two to
three hours some are 15 minutes right
and so I think you know it's edited to a
degree but I don't think you realize how
much discussion actually happens
she has investing our money it is in a
fun structure but it's her capital it's
her mind that she's worth you know I
don't know I will say she is a prolific
salesperson in the sense that like the
top three or four companies from shark
tank and I mean companies that have done
like a quarter of a billion in sales
squatty potty yeah it's those she it has
a relationship with each of those
companies and is invested in each of
those companies so I suspect quite a bit
not to mention her own patent portfolio
and the success she's
with products she's a great team yeah
and there's not an exit
yeah so I don't know where is her I
don't know I don't know well and I also
don't know I eat you know is different
right so like she does it just like in
any VC deal is different right she's
gonna go shooting a deal with me that's
different I don't know what what terms
are you know with the rest of her
companies I do know she has put all of
these companies on the map from scrub
daddy to squatty potty's companies that
have incredible consumer parlors now she
delivers yeah so I'm telling you I think
ever seems to me actually I don't have
one but it does seem I mean it does seem
very popular a pair apparently so
I guess so every well question for you
we actually get the test how do you
actually so we got it was November we oh
we asked you to be more than right and
it aired the night before Cyber Monday
it was Thanksgiving weekend this
couldn't have been a better day all that
my poor team they were wonderful they
canceled all their Thanksgivings was you
know a lot of work but um what we got
about 30 times our normal traffic but we
had an interesting experience we didn't
have this tremendous like huge spike the
night of in terms of purchases but we
ended up doing about a million dollars
in sales which at the time was a
tremendously large number for us in like
the four-day period after the show so
there's been a little bit of this
interesting thing for us that I haven't
heard many other companies have which is
we doubled like we doubled in that week
on a run rate standpoint and then we
continued doubling the next month and we
never had that decline but we didn't
have this spike in like the three hour
period that we aired yeah we had a lot
of traffic I think like a million
yeah uniques yeah so and we did I mean
we had to I mean at the time we were not
set up for that scale now we don't even
have to
about it we know we've always been on on
stripe not WooCommerce not Shopify we've
built we've built on it now and like
totally customized it it's not I know
but it's one of the big ones that
actually I think we should have gone to
Shopify but we didn't so I shouldn't
know I shouldn't name them because it's
gonna sound bad for that
yes exactly yeah so we're trying to get
more I was gonna say that valuation
right so which guy oh so yeah so we saw
really good traffic increase but it
wasn't it was a very different pattern
and Lori warned us about that she said
some companies it's like they sell out
immediately and some companies it's just
a slow kind of a slow burn so that was
what it was with us but we did not crash
which was essential stay tuned there
there may be a there may be an upcoming
and a waiting there so one of the Gloria
potentially potentially we are actually
in two years where the number I think
we're number ten on the all-time
best-selling list out of nine seasons
those socks and then squatty potty's
bombas yeah number one 250 million in
sales
yes people love it I'm gonna buy
unlimited of the best stock yeah it was
the thing I always told myself that's
cool everybody
do you love that yeah I love them but I
need more that's yeah yeah I bought the
whatever the like sixty pay or whatever
like I do five hundred pairs of socks
like laundry you know that's like one of
the best taxi to do is what I did was I
bought I only have one pair of underwear
but I owned like 30 of them yeah one
pair of socks are they on 50 of them
yeah so I never matched socks yeah it's
the greatest hat cover
yes I've been doing since I was 18
should we let's say buy the product what
do I shake do at home when I think
physically have to do so this people are
often surprised how many people we get
to take their blood at home but that's
often what it requires so like most of
our testing is pricking your finger to
draw a small sample of blood
some are saliva summer urine but
obviously there's a reason why they
normally take your blood at a lab it's
because you can analyze the most number
of markers and the the broadest
assortment of markers using blood so
it's dried blood spot testing it's like
a very frankly old-school model yes
Quest LabCorp all of the labs have dried
blood spot testing novel just means your
your pricking a finger and your dropping
blood onto a treated paper or a treated
device that is then the blood is then
drying we're not we're not we're a
middle person which if you were a VC
responding to me back in 2016 I was a
marketing company yeah right and I think
you know it's interesting when you're
like oh well you're just a middleman or
you're just marketing but I relieve us
more as okay the labs are our
manufacturing partners right you don't
buy things directly from manufacturers
typically right you buy them from a
brand so we have seven different partner
labs we work with probably the the one
that runs the majority of our business
is PerkinElmer which is a publicly
traded life sciences company they're
huge they're global and they've been
really a good partner to scale and they
have a lot of credibility they're the
worldwide leader in dried blood spot
testing so I know but you know what like
for us in our space and we're in the
medical space that's really important to
have that that stamp especially with
with all the failures that I've been
saying here Sam's thoughts on
testing samyak away I'm excited let's
get a lot of them are [__] yeah
am i right or it depends and it's
important and it's we do every test you
know it's interesting well first of all
so to correct you there's a major
difference between a food allergy and
celiac disease and then a food
intolerance or a food sensitivity okay
so but just for you know listeners
ending it is important because even
doctors just say allergy and sensitivity
is the same thing I definitely
interesting okay you know it's
interesting we have become associated
this food sensitivity testing in general
has become associated with Everly well
which I supposes like I'm proud of from
a brand standpoint but on the other hand
it's been going on for over thirty years
and there's thousands of doctors that do
both IG IgG IgA testing around the u.s.
and most people that you talk to if
you've talked to them about food
intolerance say oh yeah I have that done
at my allergist or I had done it
nutritionist or at my general
practitioner it has to be used in a
specific contest context to be valuable
and so I do think that is why it's
really important that you keep people on
how it should be used it should be used
with an elimination diet it is not a
be-all end-all
it's a guidance it is something it is
our test where we have more people
quantitatively say it's changed their
lives than any other test but and
there's good research around it for that
use but there's not good research around
is saying like it's a it diagnosis you
with an allergy it can just be used as
kind of a black-and-white guidance of
what you shouldn't shouldn't eat that's
absolutely not true so I think there's a
lot of misinformation I think there's a
lot of different types of testing and
the nomenclature gets mixed up for
things that shouldn't be used for and I
think it's great that I really well has
been known as the brand for that but
honestly we're offering a test that has
been around for decades and needs to be
used in the right way and if we can take
the lead in educating people on what
that should be then we'll do that
sexual what we call it sexual health
sti's and there's several reasons for
that one right now our tests are too
highly priced because the lab itself is
expensive for us to run the tests so we
I mean right now our single mark our
STDs are a really good price between 39
and $49 it's also HSA and FSA covered so
for some people that's a great solution
but many people for obvious reasons want
a comprehensive test and that test is I
think 201 sti's it's STI is the clinical
right yeah sexually transmitted
infections is the correct nomenclature
we call it sexual health testing because
we think that this is something people
should just be very active about for at
home it's I would say it's probably us
just from branding standpoint there's a
couple companies specialize which to be
clear should tell you how
under-resourced and served this
opportunity is because yes yes this is a
multi-billion dollar opportunity I mean
again if we're gonna riff lots of other
people can come into this space there's
a specific company that only does STI
testing but they haven't been well
funded they've struggled and we really
believe that this is not only how you
can fester closed public health gaps you
also can get people on board to then use
testing it from home over their lifetime
for any other health issue as well
people don't want to go into a clinic
you don't want to go period and our
solution you actually can not only get
your results but then you can diagnose
and treat through an independent
physician if you have a positive if it's
a relevant STI that can be treated so
it's a full-service solution and what
you're looking at right now is we have a
really good business but if you look at
the price sensitivity there's a certain
age group that's gonna be willing to pay
250 to go get a test versus going to a
clinic potentially
customers properly in first touch or do
you hope you lose money in them on their
first touch and profitably on first
touch that that is for me we're in
Austin I'm a first-time founder we're
building a sustainable business we
didn't go out and raise money on this
premise of just negative contribution
margin and then hoping well it depends
search for different categories that
search has a ceiling it does have a
ceiling even without right which total
so for that category
certainly search is great for us but
Facebook / Instagram who was for a long
time our largest acquisition channel and
both by force and by proactively moving
away we've really diversified which has
been a good move for our business some
TV we've had mixed success with we again
because we are on this profitable unit
economics from the beginning play we
when we can't fully measure attribution
and ROI on first purchase sometimes it's
hard for us to want to invest so we've
had mixed success with TV but we do
believe it's important for brand
building and category education no no
engineering product clinical a lot of it
goes into clinical and medical affairs
so we have what we have a regulatory and
compliance team that ensures that either
the lab partners we're working with or
new lab partners that were making sure
that they're meeting the highest quality
standards we're starting our own
research studies to prove outcome data
which will take time but we think is
really important we do have obviously a
healthy paid marketing budget but we're
trying to hire more in-house around
content SEO organic and those pieces as
we start to actually build out like a
healthy marketing and Jenin not just be
dependent on this like paid social thing
that we were the last few years know and
that I think is a really good if you
could I would have if I could have it's
a really important question though
said like you're a marketing company I'm
like okay so it's what little this thing
right see it with this cute little pink
on it and then just start buying traffic
what where's the I mean that's it that's
how simple it sounds what was right
we're done of the challenges beyond the
like yeah well first send traffic to a
landing page and right so we don't white
label we actually fully intend construct
and brand our kits and really what the
lab does is run the sample that's the
goal of the lab but there's also a
really complex product from an
engineering standpoint so not only
creating obviously what is somewhat
basic an e-commerce site but then a
results platform that is able to speak
with a third party physician network
translate lab results that were often
really messy and then be able to say
that in a meaningful way to consumers
and five years ago that was not as easy
from a like a UX standpoint as it is
today they also use a doctor yeah it's
for regulatory reasons it's to make sure
that you basically have a doctor in the
process of saying okay I made sure that
this test is appropriate for you I've
made sure that if there are critical
values so for example if you took our
STI test and you had an abnormal you
would have a physician call you and talk
you through your next steps and offer
you a telemedicine contact right and so
there there are checks and balances in
place you don't always have to interact
with the doctor if it's just a normal
result but there's certain like levels
of escalation so but it is it is similar
to minus FX except it's home kits and
one SFX really kind of stayed on the
quantified self her brand and never was
able to scale yeah yeah it's still out
there but it's interesting I mean there
have been a lot of companies many
especially after shark tank I would put
it in a two dozen range that launched an
Instagram create a pretty logo have a
kit
and then about six months to twelve
months later you never hear from them
again and it does speak to the power of
brands marketing and experience may our
NPS is a 60 we have a world-class
customer base I think in this case first
mover advantage really helped us in the
category it doesn't cause us to keep
winning but it mattered a lot here so
exactly world-class would be like 80 or
above right so certainly it's below that
but I think how we view it as we look at
other healthcare services and most are
around a zero to a negative don't
measure right right and so we feel good
about it product rating is four and a
half out of five stars on average and so
we do look at that and say okay this has
to be qualified it's a very favorable VC
metric one that I think has sometimes
limited action ability or limited kind
of did data-driven decision-making right
what do you do with it but we like it in
terms of saying okay just benchmark well
right right and you have this idea
you're sitting at Deloitte and you have
this personal experience where you know
that's Loco like every entrepreneur has
the stated story just like you know I
was trying to get a test I just and
behind the stories like our audience is
very entrepreneurial and they feel this
on a daily basis they have these ideas
doubts they want to bet the idea so tell
me like that oh yeah the idea that first
couple weeks you know what was what was
going through your mind what are you
doing what got you over the punker like
I'm actually gonna do this yeah I think
this is important because I it is the
real story right so I'm like oh I just
had this idea and I
we moved to Austin in a u-haul all those
things are true but there's a few thing
my husband and I in our dog there's a
few things that I think are important
it's not like I woke up one day and was
like oh I'm gonna go do this crazy thing
so I did go to Harvard and I was in this
weird time it was during the recession
in 2009 when everybody in my class in
the class above me were becoming
entrepreneurs and so you had Rent the
Runway you had Birchbox you had guilt of
years before stitch fix Oscar I had to
unicorn founders in my section alone and
at the time grabbed taxi out of Korea
and then who was out coupang both in my
section right so at the time it didn't
feel that unique but I was being exposed
to this day in and day out and so I had
this kind of roadmap for how to go about
it once I started thinking about
becoming an entrepreneur and so I the
reality is I probably spent two years on
the weekends in my spare time not making
any money but going through different
industries different business models
advising different companies on their
business plans and seeing like what
would really stick there's nothing I do
but it's really like I look back it's
kind of boring it's like over gravel I
don't know I will I will sign it but
it's it's like I would be very literal
and how I would go about evaluating all
these ideas and honestly Everly well was
probably the craziest and the worst of
the ideas for me to go and actually do
given my background no I mean it was
like travel luxury resale something like
what the real real is doing I mean house
decorating curation online like all
kinds of different spaces where there's
probably opportunity in any of those
that you do it the right way yeah to be
clear it's you know I don't know if I
took an idea from them or if I if I
actually came up with it but but um you
know the match with Everly well was not
necessarily one where you'd be like oh
she's oh right it was not obvious but it
was the one where like I realized really
early on this is a decade-long thing so
if it actually works you're in it for a
long night
no it's a couple years I mean until I
had this health experience in 2015 and
then I kind of matched the two together
so this was early 2015 I ended up
incorporating the company June 18 2015
I had dabbled I didn't
both my parents are lawyers I didn't
realize one that being an entrepreneur
was actually a career choice in a path
that you could like become good at
necessarily mean financial success you
could be a serial entrepreneur and
actually make that a career and I also
frankly didn't have a lot of confidence
so it was interesting at Harvard because
I kind of looked around and thought I
think I'm just as smart as all these
people who are like really founding
successful companies so maybe I can do
it too and I honestly did it just to see
if I could do it I never like I truly
couldn't even imagine having made a
million dollars in sales and so I'm not
sure I necessarily thought about what it
would look like today
I just thought it was a really big
opportunity and something that I wanted
to see if I could go do and that was how
I made the decision as I thought I'm
passionate I think it's a major thing I
was in the FinTech space and I thought
that was already really oversaturated by
2015 tons of apps etc and so I knew that
this was an area I didn't care about I
don't turns out I was a little wrong
about that but um but and and you know I
do think wellness FX is an example well
I think they were just ahead of their
time they were too early on the curve
right and if it's a consumer brand you
were you were right yes completely what
opportunities have you and
uncovered where you tell people man just
so you know there's this huge problem in
this industry I think we solved what
other things
yeah sure because I'm a total outsider
but but but when I hear about yeah this
isn't like price transparency which may
seem obvious and I think there's a lot
of companies that talk about in health
care doing price transparency but they
don't actually do it and even the
digital startups trying to do it they
can't actually tell you what something
will cost in healthcare so we just go
outside of insurance so that we can
actually tell people what something will
cost but if you were able to do this in
a really big way and say hey we can
accurately tell you your cost commitment
for this service I think you would crush
it and I don't with in insurance but I
think there's a much much larger growing
acceptance of consumers who are happy to
pay for something in health care as long
as they know what they're gonna get and
what it costs and so I don't know that
it has to be within insurance you also
have this HSA NFS a space that's
exploding in terms of people on FSA NHS
a plans and then what they're using
those dollars for I think there's an
interesting play there of a company
half-baked yeah man if you could be a so
if you had physicians and you said okay
I'm going to have you pay $50 any time
you see the physician we're gonna own a
pharmacy and any of your drugs are gonna
be transparently priced and you can't
use a coupon everything is the same
price and it's all generic and then if
you say okay and then I want to be able
to get you know testing done and then
they can tell you the pricing on that
but here's the problem with it you have
to actually own the supply chain and the
services chain you have to be vertically
integrated to do this because otherwise
I know but my point is you almost build
a system external to the system and you
can do this at affordable pricing the
reason health care is so expensive is
because you're adding cost into the
system through the insurers and those
contracts then when you get the bills
you're getting the bill for whatever
they didn't want to cover
that was intended like the provider
billed the insurance company what they
had hoped the insurance company would
pay not at all what it costs yes some of
them get stopped so for example like
three years ago two years ago on on
Black Friday we had a bunch of
compliance limits with our banking
system on spend in Facebook so I was
like gosh I wish there was a product
where you could actually get like a cash
advance for social media advertising now
now we're big enough to where we don't
have to use a product like a Brack Sura
but well like clear bank would do it
right so but at that time if those
solutions have been around we absolutely
would have been able to take advantage
of them and then of course they came out
I was like oh that would have been a
really good idea yeah but we really hit
a bunch of challenges with that and it
really can bring down businesses and
then I think you know other places are
how do you make like as you think about
doing a startup I mean the amount of
time we spend on contracts and HR and
legal and template izing I mean there's
so much cost in the system that I would
love to take out of it in healthcare and
highly regulated industries it's really
hard to do things quick dirty and cheap
and it's unwise
you